je crois qu'on dit elle fait par la
Mairie de Paris la pollution n'a pas
diminué parce que les voitures sont
totalement à l'arrêt les gens déserté
Paris c'est la première ville c'est la
seule vie d'Europe où les gens les
investissements à part l'euro de la les
investissements des étrangers deviennent
plus ils vont à Londres et record de
l'endettement de Paris
et je rappelle
quand même voter pour
elle-même il aurait mieux fait de le
dire avant je pense que pour plein de
gens et non mais c'est triste parce que
c'est une ville qu'on adore que j'aime
tellement pour une raison c'est pour ça
qu'il faudrait qu'elle s'explique en
fait toujours des choses pour lui
demander
j'ai été choqué non mais moi j'étais
choqué par sa réaction dans la vidéo à
chaque fois qu'elle se fait prendre un
parti et l'ignore elle dialogue avec les
gens là où d'autres hommes Macron il y
va voilà il y va et elle ça montre bien
le mépris le fait qu'elle est
complètement déconnectée des gens et de
la population en général et ça moi ça
c'est vrai que le président
quel que soit la personne il rentre
dedans elle elle Sarkozy elle est contre
le débat donc j'ai vu qu'il y allait
encore Macron
le deuxième il sait que c'est fini il
est roule hein il a disparu totalement
il s'occupe de rien politique
on est sur un Hidalgo toi en fait tu
mets ta vie pendant ce temps toi c'est
pour ça que ton émission est bordélique
le samedi moi je le disais les
bordélique bordélique tu vois comme j'ai
fait comme ton cerveau
non non 719000 non 780000
780000 c'est moi qui décide tu vas faire
719 je te le dis fais gaffe je te gagne
et quand tu feras le mignon tu pourras
ouvrir ta gueule pour l'instant rien
ferme ta gueule
voilà tu sais ce qui va se passer un
jour
[Rires]
non non mais je vais partir de la maison
je vais quitter la maison je vais me
laver je vais dire tes 719000 tu vas te
les [ __ ] à part dans le cul je vais
rentrer chez moi je te le dis je te le
dis déjà le temps alors hein le temps
que tu rentres chez toi avec la
circulation et les rats à cette heure-ci
je t'aurais déjà rattrapé par le trou de
balle je le ferai pas aujourd'hui mais
j'aimerais tellement qu'un jour tu me
disais de gentillesse j'arrête pas
arrête mais quelle mais c'est pas
possible
780 quel côté toi
[Rires]
on se calme ah ouais c'est vrai c'est
fusionnel